et
cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous chams
eddine hafiz bonjour bonjour bienvenue
sur ce plateau recteur de la grande
mosquée de paris est l'une des plus
importantes de france on va revenir dans
un instant sur le texte que vous publiez
chez calmann-lévy d'abord quelques mois
quelques mots du mois sacré du ramadan
qui a commencé samedi dernier après deux
ans de restrictions allié au co vide les
musulmans de france se prépare à quelque
chose de plus détendu de plus chaleureux
d'abord il commença à reprendre leurs
habitudes de vie spirituelle dans les
mosquées puisque après la rupture du
jeûne il y à de nombreux fidèles qui
viennent à la mosquée notamment pour
faire ce qu'on appelle les prières
surérogatoires il y a une véritable
ambiance puisque pendant deux années on
n'a pas pu le faire et donc il y a si
vous voulez une
effervescence habituelle puisque le
ramadan est devenu je dirais à la fois
une obligation religieuse mais en même
temps un fait de société puisque les
musulmans générale en france dans les
immeubles avec les voisins partagent
toujours je dirais ce moment festif delà
de la rupture du jeûne donc c'est un
moment très important pour les musulmans
et je pense que pour tous les français
un mois sacré dans un contexte politique
évidemment particulier il a commencé une
semaine tout juste avant le premier tour
de la présidentielle et vous signez donc
cet essai dont le titre résonne n'en
déplaise à certains nous sommes des
enfants de la république qui vient de
sortir chez calmann lévy pourquoi
faut-il en 2022 écrire un texte pareil
et surtout avec un titre pareil bah
écoutez je crois qu'il y à un certain
nombre de candidats à la présidence de
la république qui nous dénie je dirais
ce statut d'être des citoyens français
d'avoir les mêmes droits que nos autres
compatriotes et c'est pour cela que j'ai
tenu à rappeler que les musulmans
toujours été au rendez vous que ce soit
pendant les grandes guerres que se soit
dans les moments de crise on l'a vu même
au début de cette qu'ovide 19 qui nous
avait tous tétanisés les musulmans ont
joué leur rôle ils ont participé à cette
solidarité nationale et à chaque fois
que nécessaire les musulmans toujours
été présent pourquoi aujourd'hui leur
dénie ce droit d'être français à part
entière est-ce que redire et réécrire
que les musulmans de france je vous cite
attey adhère totalement sans arrière
pensée à la nation française ce n'est
pas d'une certaine façon en miroir
donner une forme de consistance à ceux
qui pensent le contraire bah écoutez
d'abord il faut rappeler que les
musulmans sont des citoyens comme les
autres ils ont toujours participé à la
vie citoyenne et aujourd'hui leur dénier
ce droit en disant que c'est des
immigrés alors qu'on est je crois arrivé
à la quatrième voire même la cinquième
génération aujourd'hui la plupart des
jeunes musulmans sont nets en france ils
sont en france qu'ils ne connaissent que
la france est aujourd'hui leur dire
qu'il faut qu'ils repartent et repart
tout et c'est pour cela que j'ai tenu
véritablement a rappelé que d'abord
république et islam ne sont pas des
concepts qui s'oppose bien au contraire
j'ai toujours dit que l'islam s'adapter
de manière extrêmement naturelle je
dirais aux lois de la république nous
l'avons rappelé gelé martelé à plusieurs
reprises et je ne suis pas le seul
heureusement les musulmans n'ont jamais
cherché à avoir des lois spécifiques ils
se sont toujours adaptés aux lois de la
république ils les respectent les lois
de la république sont au dessus de
toutes les lois même la loi divine et ça
il faut le rappeler à ceux qui nous
dénie ce droit d'être républicain tout
simplement certains effectivement des
candidats dans cette campagne électorale
à sion leur discours anti-islam eric
zemmour je le cite disait encore il y a
quelques jours que dans l'islam il ya
selon lui une volonté de régenter la vie
des individus qui est contradictoire je
le cite toujours avec la civilisation
française ce qui lui fait dire que
l'islam est incompatible avec la france
d'abord je voudrais dire à eric zemmour
qu'il a très peu de connaissances de
l'islam s'il connaissait véritablement
le coran il prend comme ça il fait son
petit marché pour essayer d'alimenter la
haine qu'il a contre les musulmans et
contre sa propre histoire puisque à
chaque fois après les musulmans c'est
l'algérie qui stigmatise à maintes
reprises donc moi je crois qu'il devrait
prendre un cours je l'invite à venir la
grande mosquée de paris pour peut-être
rencontrer nos imams et se faire une
autre idée peut-être de l'islam à force
de répéter je crois qu'il qui s'y
croient qu'il s'est pris à ce jeu
d'essayer à chaque fois de montrer que
l'islam est totalement incompatible
alors que l'islam est là depuis déjà
plusieurs siècles la grande mosquée de
paris a été construite je dirais dans un
quartier mythique quartier latin devant
le jardin des plantes pas très loin de
notre dame est ce qu'un jour cette
mosquée a posé un problème même dans
cette architecture lorsque vous êtes en
haut du minaret que vous voyez paris
comme ça sous vos yeux vous rendez
compte que des immeubles haussmanniens
avec cette architecture
arabo mauresque neuneu ne viennent pas
du tout il n'y avait pas une verrue la
mosquée de paris n'est pas une verrue
dans cette très belle architecture de la
ville de paris bien au contraire et
c'est pour cela que je voudrais qu'eric
zemmour il dit qu'il n'est pas raciste
moi je veux bien le croire mais qu'il
arrête de marteler des choses qui sont
totalement fausses il n'a jamais eu de
contradicteurs et moi je l'est déjà je
lui ai déjà répondu en 2010 il n'a pas
daigné me répondre à l'époque il ne
voulait pas débattre avec moi moi je
souhaiterais quand même un jour que nous
puissions nous rencontrer parler
ensemble qu'il y en avait fait de soi je
crois de vous rencontrer
avant d'être oui mais vous savez quand
on considère que l'islam et l'islamisme
c'est la même chose que les immigrés
doivent être tous je dirais chassés de
france est ce que pour moi recteur de la
grande mosquée de paris ça serait facile
de le recevoir maintenant que les
élections seront terminées quand il y
aura un nouveau président de la
république et quand lui reviendra à sa
place de journaliste je le rencontrerai
vraiment de façon très amicale ou qui a
incarné un islam dits modérés vous dites
souvent que la frontière doit être
hermétique entre ce qui relève de la foi
est ce qui est le politique au seul
l'espace de la cité et même un chapitre
dans le livre qui s'appelle la politique
nuit gravement à l'islam qu'est ce que
ça veut dire à écouter aujourd'hui alors
c'est pas uniquement les musulmans mais
moi je pense qu'il est important pour
nous tous de faire vraiment une
séparation entre l'islam qui est une
religion de religions monothéistes à
l'instar du christianisme et du judaïsme
nous sommes la religion qui est venu
après ces deux grandes religions et
l'islamisme qui est une idéologie
politique à partir du moment
a été aussi sûre qui est une réalité et
aujourd'hui il faut faire le distinguo
entre les deux on ne peut pas considérer
que l'islam est une est une idéologie
politique c'est ce que cet amalgame
que je refuse de la part d'eric zemmour
aujourd'hui l'islam ne tue pas l'islam
ne ne sépare pas c'est l'islamisme qui
est aujourd'hui la véritable difficulté
dans notre pays si nous faisons le
distinguo on verra qu'on pourra
véritablement parce que c'est notre
ennemi comment ceux qui détiennent cette
idéologie politique l'utilisent qu'il
instrumentalise pour en fait
retirer la composante musulmane de
france de l'ensemble la communication en
fait c'est le même travail que fait eric
zemmour et l'extrême droite de manière
générale ils ne veulent pas il ne
supporte pas que la composante musulmane
de france soient complètement intégrées
à l'intérieur de la communauté nationale
c'est un jeu qu'ils utilisent pour
pouvoir les deux avoir une légitimité
les islamistes qui vous disent 'vous
voyez musulmans vous n'êtes pas aimé par
les français et de l'autre côté monsieur
eric léser mots et je dirais il n'y a
pas que lui et malheureusement qui
disent vous voyez les musulmans ne
peuvent pas s'intégrer dans la
communauté nationale il faut les rejeter
en fait c'est le même objectif c'est la
même façon de travailler mais ils ont
des titres différents mais moi je trouve
que l'un et l'autre sont extrêmement
dangereux mes partenaires objectif
écrivez vous vous avez rappelé il ya
quelques semaines vous avez appelé il ya
quelques semaines tous les français et
pas que les musulmans de france à
s'inscrire sur les listes électorales
pour sanctionner je vous cite les
chantres du racisme son site est
d'ailleurs dans cette tribune aucun nom
ce qui a valu à certains candidats de se
sentir visé sur ce discours raciste
qu'on a entendu il faut le dire cette
dernière semaine de part et d'autre
comment vous expliquez que se verront et
sauter à ce point écoutez quand il ya un
malaise dans la société on cherche
toujours
je dirais
des groupes de personnes qui puissent
être accusé de tous les maux ça fait un
moment donné les musulmans étaient
tétanisés par ce qui se passait il
suffisait qu'il y ait le moindre coup de
feu hier vous savez il ya un bus qui a
brûlé dans paris on s'est tous posé la
question est-ce que ce n'était pas un
acte terroriste est ce que ce n'était
pas derrière encore une fois à quelques
jours du premier tour donc on a le droit
de se poser des questions vous imaginez
quel réflexe aujourd'hui nous avons avec
toutes les attaques que nous recevons en
permanence il suffit qu aujourd'hui vous
imaginez que quand on dit allah o akbar
c'est devenu une expression
mortifère attention c'est quelqu'un qui
va tuer alors que les musulmans de
manière extrêmement serein de manière
paisible dans les mosquées lorsqu'ils
font leurs prières il utilise cette
expression
moi même je l'explosé l'expriment
plusieurs fois dans la journée il faut
qu'on arrête cette amalgame qui met
aujourd'hui malheureusement d'abord en
danger cette cette société qui
effectivement fracturée qui sort d'un
d'une pandémie extrêmement dur qui a
effectivement mis en péril à la fois des
familles mais aujourd'hui des gens qui
se posent des questions sur leur avenir
professionnel il y a comme on l'a dit
cette difficulté du pouvoir d'achat qui
vraiment été la première question que se
posent les français est aujourd'hui bien
évidemment quand on essaie de trouver je
dirais des des boucs émissaires et ben
c'est les musulmans aujourd'hui que eric
zemmour à trouver très facilement pour
essayer à la fois de justifier toute sa
campagne de tout cela comment quelqu'un
qui aspire à devenir président de la
république au lieu de réunir les enfants
d'une même patrie il fait en sorte de
les fractures et pas uniquement entre
les musulmans avec les juifs il a quand
même été extrêmement loin puisqu'il fait
du révisionnisme il essaie de
réhabiliter maréchal pétain il se pose
la question sur d'innocents cela fera de
la fratrie fuste enfin regarder en 2022
alors est-ce que c'est uniquement la
liberté d'expression qui permet cela
parce qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement ce
type de discours va voir une
amplification au sein de la société on
va dire de toutes les manières comment
quelqu'un qui se permet dans tous les
médias deux-tiers de de tenir ce type de
propos comment aujourd'hui je ne peux
pas le faire lorsque je suis au café du
coin c'est ça qui est dangereux enfin il
a été condamné à plusieurs reprises
l'audience merci beaucoup merci d'être
venu ce matin sur le plateau de paris
direct chems eddine hafiz et ce texte
donc qui résonne n'en déplaise à
certains nous sommes des enfants de la
république chez calmann-lévy merci
encore merci beaucoup de journée à vous
on se retrouve juste après la pause avec
damien coquet
[Musique]